now and again you might stumble across
an entry in the scp foundation archive
that is far more than meets the eye as
you are probably already aware
sometimes the foundation's numerical scp
designations can be referencing an
entity a creature an object a location
or even a combination of linked
anomalies all sharing a version of the
same number such is partially the case
with scp-4812
in this instance the designation number
4812 doesn't refer to one singular item
or entity instead it is more of a
collective designation an umbrella term
for three distinct separate but
connected anomalies we've got a lot of
ground to cover here so without further
ado let's take a look at scp-4812
better known collectively as wrath we'll
begin in a cavern deep beneath ales in
the south of france where we find the
first of the entities to share the
designation
scp-4812 this creature large and without
its own distinct form is referred to as
scp-4812-s
it possesses a number of long appendages
that protrude from its amorphous body
each one covered in a sticky adhesive a
sort of glue-like substance in addition
each appendage as well as the rest of
scp-4812-s's body is covered in fine
hair that is also hydrophobic meaning
that it does not absorb water and in
fact actively repels it these tendrils
extend deep into the walls of the
caverns surrounding the creature
scp-4812-s also has an inherent latent
ability to affect anyone that visually
perceives it in other words look upon
this creature at your own peril and we
don't mean that looking at it will drive
you mad the fact is that nobody has been
able to look directly at this creature
without suffering a horrific grisly
death upon taking even the quickest
glimpse of
scp-4812-s the person observing will
suffer the same effect they would if
their eyes brain and entire nervous
system had been dipped in caustic acid
yes this creature instantly melts down
on a molecular level anyone who is brave
enough or foolish enough to directly
look at it that means a pain unlike any
you could imagine bleeding through the
skin and all orifices paralysis
asphyxiation and then death in that
order humans cannot directly interact
with the creature unless it is submerged
in total darkness where they cannot
perceive it visually the anomalous
hazard of this entity even extends to
photos or video recordings of scp-4812-s
however the effect is not as immediate
or violent when someone just looks at an
image or video of it still you might
want to check that your brain isn't
melting after this video is over just to
be safe beyond killing anyone that sees
it
scp-4812-s does very little staying
quite still in its cave behind the
maximum security doors the foundation
has put in place at the entrance so
that's our first of the scp-4812s
who's next how about scp-4812-1
an approximately 15-meter tall humanoid
made of platinum this entity appears
vaguely skeletal with traces of tungsten
and other metal compounds in its
composition
scp-4812-e remains at a constant body
temperature of 0.000031
kelvin or almost negative 460 degrees
fahrenheit however this entity can also
absorb the heat around it without
changing its own temperature
reducing our cell at room temperature to
absolute zero in around 16 seconds flat
and it's because of this that
scp-4812-e is often surrounded by a
layer of frozen air and water much like
the other creature it shares a
designation with close interactions with
scp-4812-e
are often deadly stand too close and the
air around you would drop in temperature
rapidly the water within your body would
freeze and in seconds you would die even
with the use of a specially insulated
suit you would be lucky to gain a few
short moments of added protection the
only thing that weakens
scp-4812-e's effect is to expose it to
extreme heat although this does not stop
the temperature absorption entirely just
slows it but it's through the constant
application of high temperatures that
the foundation has been able to keep
scp-4812-e contained in a thermally
controlled vault kept intensely hot at
all times finally we have the last of
the three designated as
scp-4812-k and we recommend anyone with
a bug phobia to look away now this
creature is an enormous winged insect
almost like a cross between a stag
beetle and a scorpion in some of the
physical traits it shares with them
while its size might be significantly
bigger measuring 180 meters long the
insect possesses two large pinchers four
legs four wings that extend from its
back and a long segmented tail with a
pointed barb at the tip yes this creepy
crawly would need a lot more than just a
can of raid to get rid of it but perhaps
most strangely of all is scp-4812-k's
face not the typical insect eyes and
mouth you would expect but the face of a
human male much like its cavern dwelling
counterpart
scp-4812-k tends to not do all that much
when left alone it can usually be found
flying through the upper stratosphere
only really moving when it flaps its
wings you might have a hard time trying
to spot it though as its body is coated
in reflected chitin in other words the
bug's exoskeleton refracts light away
from it and makes it almost invisible
while the scp foundation has made
attempts to secure and contain this
gigantic flying insect after they
learned of its existence the creature's
sheer size and strength have destroyed
any fighter jets or drones they have
sent after it it seems impervious to
damage from conventional weapons with
anything fired at it being almost
perfectly reflected and directed back
towards the shooter all the foundation
can really do is hope that nobody else
spots it and keeps a close eye on
scp-4812-k
through regular surveillance above all
though one procedure remains consistent
and all of the utmost importance with
every aspect of scp-4812
never under any circumstances can any of
them be allowed to interact with the
other two so what could possibly connect
these three creatures an amorphous
entity that kills anyone who looks at it
a giant humanoid male made of platinum
that alters temperature without
absorbing heat and a winged insect that
is almost perfect at reflecting anything
around it they all seem to be pretty
disconnected
yet their common thread must be pretty
significant for all three to share the
title of scp-4812
indeed if they had no relation to each
other they could each have their own
unique number and what is the mysterious
fourth redacted entity that is also
referred to as scp-4812
the answers to this multitude of
questions aren't exactly straightforward
still there does exist a series of
anomalous documents and items that the
foundation has recovered that features
some of the necessary information
recovered from marcus duis a dutch
collector of anomalous artifacts these
items are referred to as the connington
set named after winston j connington an
english archaeologist and occultist
whose research led the foundation to the
discovery of a number of scps among the
various artifacts of the connington set
is a journal kept by connington himself
featuring depictions of the different
scp-4812 creatures and notes recording
his findings the set also features three
hefty tomes written in german over the
course of many years that contain
multiple archaic coordinates in one an
addition in italian by another author
seems to shed a little light on scp-4812
the translation of this section tells of
an ancient kingdom respected above all
others known either as the house of
apollon or the sky kings of all europe
the first ruler of this kingdom was
allegedly a descendant of the king of
crimson skies or asem the first man
these sky kings ruled over what is now
modern-day europe for a hundred
generations conquering all who oppose
them among their adversaries were those
faithful to the iron god presumably the
mechanites the ancient machine
worshiping religion that preceded the
church of the broken god eventually
however complacency reared its ugly head
and sky king saras viii von apollyon
looked beyond the realms of men hoping
to find new land to conquer sarius viii
assembled his forces the largest army
ever seen and set his sights on the
lands of the fairfolk more commonly
known as fairies nowadays these fair
folk were already engaged in conflict
with their southern neighbors the
children of the moon and were
drastically underprepared for soros's
approaching forces within two weeks the
fairies were scattered driven from their
lands there was however a sole survivor
a fae princess who was captured and
faced the grim fate of being taken as a
trophy but the princess had other plans
while being taken back to the sky king's
domain she cast a curse upon the house
of apollon hensarus viii in particular a
horrific storm swept the returning ships
as the fey princess prayed to an ancient
nameless god for vengeance against her
people's conquerors according to legend
the change that had her shackled to
sarus's ship caught fire and the blaze
spread until it had burned the sky
king's ship to ash it has even been said
that the same chains then wrapped around
saurus himself dragging him down into
the ocean's depths then to defend
against any further dark magic from the
remaining fair folk ceres ix appointed
four kings to defend his kingdom by now
you might still be wondering what any of
this has to do with scp-4812
but don't worry we're getting there we
promise so as the story continues the
remaining ships were still able to bring
the fae princess back and she was
brought before soros's heir sars ix von
apollyon who imprisoned her for what she
had done the princess was sent into a
sealed dungeon deep beneath the oceans
this prison is heavily implied to be the
first of the scp-4812 entities better
known to us as scp-4812-s
however the explanations of the heatsink
platinum humanoid and the reflective
flying insect are a little harder to
decipher from winston j connington's
journal while most of connington's notes
are written in a cipher a few sections
have been translated according to him
from her prison deep below the earth the
voice of the fairy princess was able to
communicate with the souls of the four
knights protecting saris the ninth's
kingdom as a result the sky king was
forced to banish them and this brought
forth what connington referred to as the
great profanities without the knight's
defense some force known as the vinnie
venice the first profanity was able to
cast its cold hand over saras's only
daughter killing her a creature whose
presence can drain the heat from a
person sounds an awful lot like
scp-4812-e
huh in retaliation for his daughter's
death saris drew up an ancient spear
called the godless lance and struck the
being down casting it into the earth's
molten core and subduing
scp-4812-e with the intense heat below
another section describes the king of
many faces la menoland the creature we
know as scp-4812-k
connington's findings describe this
entity slaughter of the deva a
neighboring kingdom the enormous insect
appeared from the space beyond spaces
and would deflect perfectly any attack
made against it before taking the faces
of the deva and returning to the skies
but there was one final profanity known
only as the profane dark the legend
continues with this profanity a dark
black smear rising from the graves of
the fair folk it soaked through the
earth and burst from below claiming the
sky king and dragging him into the
endless void as it pulled him away saras
cursed the profane dark calling it yash
the last great foe of man watching his
kingdom fall without the protection of
his four knights all the sky king could
utter was one repeated word breath
now go check out
scp-1461 house of the worm and
scp-5000y the full story compilation for
more wild stories from the universe of
the scp foundation